Hello everybody!
Oh my god, my voice is so strange.
It's been a week of non-stop jokies streaming!
Hell yeah!
Non-stop these!
Nuts.
I'm sorry.
It was just set up right there.
Anyway guys, hello, hello everybody.
Today we're gonna be playing This was selected by your, got
him, this was selected by your fellow member goons of a game
series that they all really, really wanted me to start.
It was, oh wait, it wasn't in the battle royale.
It was just, everybody was just, it was a pull, I think.
I don't remember how even got Armored Court in the first
place.
I don't even remember.
Oh yeah, it was like, it was like, we either do, it was like
Armored Court or Battle Royale.
So unlike DD Dinosaur, where it went through the Battle
Royale, Civil War with the Dragoons, all your member goons
unanimously voted on Armor Corps and avoided bloodshed for
one, for at least 30 minutes before we moved on to the next
war.
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you into any other Mecca like Mazinger Z?
Well, the only, to be fair, I do like big robots, but the
only big robots...
media I've consumed was transformers so I did you should
build Gundams but the mini Gundams because my uncle was a
huge Gundam fan before he got married and then his wife made
him um sell most of his collection because she's like we are
in a we are adults now and then because like before my uncle
got for those who didn't know um um I told the story before
but my uncle was like huge weeb um whenever i visit him he
his entire all his book shows were like filled with manga
and Gundams um and he even had like little balls too like
from the anime and everything like I don't remember from you
remember the little ball guys because I didn't I don't
consume a lot of Gundam media but I did like the chibi
Gundams that was a Gundam SD um where they were transported
back into like like um back into like one of the dynasties
and or like one of the feudal periods and then they're like
wearing these like samurai outfits and everything yeah he
even had those haru bob um figures too um but yeah i used to
make gun dumb sd figures uh and stuff uh like the really
tiny ones where they have like anime eyes i don't remember
what they were called but they were like medieval feudal
period Gundams where they were some might sometimes in like
night armor or like samurai armor and stuff um anyway uh but
yeah Yeah, that's the, and then my uncle was a huge Gundam
fan, and he would always buy like new mini, like new Gundams
to put together, to piece together and everything.
And he had like all, like he had a huge manga collection
too.
And oh yeah, I think I had the Three Kingdoms SD Gundams.
I'm pretty sure.
I just don't remember, but like I didn't paint them or
anything because I was too, my parents didn't trust me with
paint, so I just put on the stickers and everything.
And then I just displayed it.
They did get me the markers, but, you know, the markers
weren't that great, especially when I was like a kid.
Well, I was in middle school, but even then, I wasn't that
great with the markers too.
So I tried to use the markers that they got me where instead
of paint, they use markers.
So like color on, you can color on the Gundams.
But then I wasn't great with it.
So I didn't like how it looked.
And I was just like, you know, fuck yeah, I'm just, it's
just going to be.
be like vanilla Gundam I was just like vanilla Gundam no
paint whatsoever just the stickers um but that's like my
extent of doing Gundam stuff uh but yeah my uncle um he got
married and then his wife did not like his Gundam collection
nor his manga collection and she's like we need more room
for the kids uh when we have kids so like he used to have
like a room for like Gundam stuff anime shit and everything
um when they moved to like when they got together uh and
everything and then she's like well now that we're married
we have to get rid of that so we have more room to we got
more room for uh for god and uh she was really religious too
we have more room for god and the kids um so so he got the
basically got got rid of most of his collection and
everything um and yeah now i guess i don't know what he's up
to now i don't know i feel so sorry that's the never marry
jack no just find someone that will appreciate your hobbies
that's really it just find someone to appreciate your
hobbies and um and like enjoy your hobbies with you or if
they don't like your if they like you know don't share the
same hobbies at least Let you have your hobby needs God or
anime the toughest choice in the world
Yeah, anyway But being single is safer.
What if she tells me to get rid of my doki collection?
There's an easy solution guys just marry a dragon and then
think about it dragon you can combine your collections
together and you can save money because you can just buy one
of or or two actually no wait wait actually this two you
share your finances together to buy more joki merch like
yeah you can make your collections kiss imagine that guys as
basic not you can make your collection kiss and everything
now this is yes but then now you can share your finance
together and and then buy more jokey merch with your shared
bank account metty thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you you'll have to kill me to make me throw away my
jokey merch oh and thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you thank you trade they give a super chat thank you
thank you praying that uncle has a storage unit he hides in
from time to time with all this stuff back to rest and thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you husband you left
room for 13 zaku and a goof but no room for christ thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you slide thank you for
the gift of ship thank you thank you simple thank you to
super chat thank you thank you woman gotta ruin everything
shake my head thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you x thank you the super chat thank you thank you oh yeah
it's like the beanie baby divorce who's gonna get which
dokey merch she's like what if we get a divorce dokey what
if she takes half my dokey merch you buy exact that's why
you each have to buy one of each dokey merch so if there was
a divorce then you can split the dokey merch collection in
half equally guys so you don't have to worry about it there
won't be a beany baby divorce Papa Smurf, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She only wants me for my Doki merch.
Mr. Broken Bomb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're just married Doki Bird to not get rid of Doki Bird.
Doki, sorry, he's getting to not get rid of Doki Merch and
get directly from the source.
Still gotta pay, though.
You think I'm doing handouts?
In fact, I'll charge triple.
If you want directly from the source, I'll be like, you're
going to get triple, you're going to get charged triple the
price, the family discount.
Boo.
There's no benefits here.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will you sign my crookie at Zipongo to give me leverage?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the reminder, but Zipongo, for those who don't
know, I will be at Zipongo like later today at 625 p.m.
to, sorry, that was the meeting grade.
Let me double check this.
It doesn't make me professional for a second before we go
back to Doki Bird divorce, the Doki Bird divorce trial, the
Doki Merch divorce trials.
Anyway, so at 625 to 640, I'm going to be able to do that.
I will be at Zipungu on a giant billboard truck with Matara
Khan.
And we're going to be doing a meeting greet there.
So if you are going to be at Zipungu later today, there will
be a recordings of Matara and I.
We did like, I think we did like two recordings.
I don't know if they are going to play two recordings, both
recordings.
But we also have, the meeting greet is not recorded by it.
We will be talking to you in person.
It's not like we did like, hello fellow Dragoon and...
Momo?
How are you?
Like, it's not like we're gonna be doing, like, the meeting
greeting's not recorded.
It's live, by the way, just so you guys know.
We didn't do, like, pretend meeting greets there.
We didn't record pretend meeting greets, where it's, like,
insert question here.
It's like, what would you, do you want to talk about
Zipongo?
And then we wait five seconds.
Wow, I also love Zipongo.
How do you feel today?
And then we wait five seconds.
I'm glad you we're enjoying the concert.
Anyway.
Anyway, so we will have meet and greets there in live.
Live, by the way.
It's going to be live.
It's not going to be pre-recorded.
But there is pre-recorded recordings from Matara and I
that's going to be playing throughout.
Like, click the sound board.
Like, we record specific segments.
And then it'll just like, it's like those Disney meet and
greets.
You know the Disney virtual meet and greets played specific
animations and then there's a voiceover guy in the back just
being like um just pre-recorded and everything um anyway but
yes we will be at the brookside the roseboat pasadena uh ca
um and it's actually today it is today yay uh so yeah you're
gonna be there in a bit um check out the amazing artists
that's gonna be there aido uh hana man of admission Teddy
Lloyd, 10 feet, like all amazing artists, Japanese artists
there.
We're going to be doing pre-recorded segments and also with
Matara and also meeting group Matara, live meeting group
with Matara.
Anyway, all right, professional stuff out of the way.
I'm also going to be, I forgot to do this last stream.
I just remember that too.
I'm sorry, I'm a bit of a mess.
I know I keep saying that every day, but every day, almost
every stream.
Just mine has just been, the last two months, mine's just
been...
but anyway um i forgot to do this last stream but i'll be
giving away three codes three game codes for gold gold
adventure gold uh because they provided me with some game
codes and i forgot to give that away because the yonder egg
killed all my people i was gonna do at the end of the stream
and then the yonder egg fucking slaughtered my entire town
so like in like mere seconds like it overwhelmed me so much
because i was like what happened i was just like what the
fuck happened everything was fine what happened everything
was so fine like she was she seemed so happy um yeah yeah
give the coast the dragoons of all the dragoons that she
killed everyone she Not everyone.
I think the town's going to be okay.
I think maybe the town's going to be okay, guys.
Anyway.
So I'll be giving away three game codes.
Three gold, gold, adventure, not armor cord, but three gold,
gold, adventure, gold game codes late, like at the end of
the stream, guys.
So you're sticking out by the end of the stream.
I won't be doing any long stream today.
They'll most likely be around two hours-ish, because like I
said, my voice is pretty streamed at the moment.
have to do the meet and greets with Matara later on today so
that's why uh uh so that's why today won't be a super long
stream but I didn't want to start the series today um anyway
what else what else do I have to say uh oh yes this is my
very first time playing armor core I don't know much
anything much about the franchise other than big giant
robots uh that's really my knowledge of armor core um I
never played any other games before but I know a lot of you
dragoons love this game and this series and this franchise
so i can't wait i can't wait to try out myself uh yeah yeah
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you have an
armor core now get revenge on the yonder it thank you thank
you thank you uh solid thank you the super chat thing thank
you thank you the dopey merch goes on the prenup no cadet
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you patro acid
thank you the super chat thing thank you So it's more like
Half-Life 2, where Doki just appears on all government news.
Broadcast streams.
Remind you that buying merch is not optional.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, thank you for the super chat.
Well, Doki told me to marry a dragon.
Hi, I'm 5'11", 190 pounds.
Got a car, house, and good health insurance.
And a job if he has good health insurance, guys.
Please don't take my Doki merch in the divorce.
that oh she's that oh she society is single everybody you
can you want to you use my chat as a dating website if you
want as a dating profile
just put on asl
uh oh my god wait wait who was it baluro thank you so much
for the gift that ships holy shit thank you oh my god thank
you so much for the huge amount of support only dragons guys
oh the best dragon dating website
for drab mate buy dragons for dragons so thank you again
gaming for uh the 50 gift the chest thank you thank you papa
thank you with super chat thank you thank you uh whoa thank
you with super chat thank you thank you you're one of the
most hardworking women in entertainment keep being beautiful
fun and quirky thank you i really appreciate it thank you so
much i really appreciate it guys sometimes i feel like i
don't work hard enough because i've been like i've been
slacking in some parts um my manager wanted to get me me in
a call today and then i was like he was like when you wake
up we gotta get in a call to go over stuff and then i woke
up at He's like, I was like, I don't think we're going to be
getting a call soon.
Okay, I should say, can you make me a list of stuff to go
over for today?
I'll definitely go over them today before you wake up.
Whoops.
Long goons just wouldn't understand.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I got a super chat.
Dish dog.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
I've been burned before, but I woke up because like
yesterday, yesterday, he was, I was like, can you make me
listen?
I'll definitely go over it today.
And I did not go like before you wake up.
And I didn't do that because I was sort of like emo-ing.
And he woke up.
He's like, you didn't go over the list today.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I was, I, I, because like today, yesterday I was like trying
to figure out the schematics for the dual PC setup.
And I don't think it's going to work in my tiny ass PC room.
Because like I was thinking how bad it's going to be with
two, I know I could get like a portable air conditioning
everything.
But I was just like, oh man, it's going to be, I don't know.
It's like so risky.
Like it's going to be like a fucking sauna.
Because right now it's already a fucking sauna.
So that was like emo-ing because I was just like, I don't
know what to do.
I don't know how to make this work.
I might not be able to get this to work.
And then I spent that entire time after stream, after the
Fortnite too, emoing about it.
So then he woke up, I was like, hey, you said you were gonna
work on it before I wake up.
Yeah, and then I was, and so then he was like, I've been
burned before, but I will make you the list.
And then I just saw, he's like, he doesn't trust me today
he's just like that's what you said yesterday toki so but
this time for real though for this time i will go over the
list that he makes me today for real um and i see thank you
for the magenta sofa thank you thank you um i'm so happy
you're playing one of my oh nice what's that again what's
that number um playing one of my favorite game series good
luck in course six it's a lot more simplified and accessible
than the earlier entries most importantly have fun building
your mech and committing war crimes for money yay so like
just a regular dokey stream i mean that's the usual dokey
stream stuff um next evening the super chat thingy thank you
okay but if i was your manager i wouldn't trust you either
what do you mean look into these eyes and telling me, you
trust me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Magic.
Can you translate in French on Google?
Translate 51.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Magic.
Thank you.
I know that has to be something weird in French.
It's always something weird.
It's like the one where about the seal.
I don't remember I saw a clip of some guy.
finding a French girl in game and then oh the mic echo
echoes because this I'm I have my bottle of water my giant
bottle of water and I'm like hello hello what is that sealed
one where okay so some guy I don't remember what game I
think it was apex encountering a French girl and then he was
like uh he was like can you say this in french it was like a
seal something about seals and i don't remember uh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah seal apparently to pronounce seal in french
is fuck so i think it's like it's like fuck me or something
but like like he she just said fuck me or something and if
you were like Oh my god, she said it Alright, like Google
Trans Like French Or English to French Alright, what is it?
Luckily, you guys can't hear it Oh, that's what it is A
seal, a seal pushed me Oh yeah, so I'll let you hear that
one This one is the seal one This is a seal one.
And it's a seal pushed me.
That's a seal pushed me.
French is beautiful.
French is so beautiful.
Oh, it was in hell.
I just remember it was a three, man.
Yeah.
It's a seal pushed me.
That's what it means.
A seal pushed me.
I'm mad.
I love seals.
Wow.
What happens next?
What are you talking about?
Pussy is push, guys.
God.
French is so beautiful.
Such a romantic language.
So beautiful.
I'm crying.
So romantic.
Truly.
French is truly the language of love.
is.
Alright.
Don't you learn French in Canada?
Yeah, but like, I actually learned, I learned American,
like, not American French, sorry.
I was an American international school.
So, um, so I initially learned French.
Um, because like, if you guys didn't know, French in Canada
is, like, different from French in the rest of the world.
So, when I learned French, uh, I learned like france french
i didn't learn canadian french so like if you learn french
in canada there's apparently a sort of like an accent um
there's an accent when you uh when canadian speak french and
then like apparently it's like it's like sort of like a how
did i say it it's like there's like a specific tone in there
that's very different than like french french like france
french versus canadian french and also like the way people
say stuff too i was like looking It's like, I don't remember
the, yeah, yeah, because it's like based off of like
Quebecois and Quebec French.
Yeah, so like it has, yeah, it has a very specific accent
and slang to it.
So it's like you go to like, I don't even know what the
accent is because I don't hear a lot of French, Canadian
French to compare.
Because like I said, majority I've learned and like the
place, like I live like the, the, the, The province I live
also does not speak a lot of French too.
I don't think I've ever, I think I barely hear French in the
province I live because it's like very far.
It's on the West Coast and it's the, you know, West Coast is
very far from East Coast.
Yeah, West Coast is very far from East Coast.
So we're more closer to English than we are to French.
You like, for in Canada, the law is that everything has to
be bilingual.
Everything has to be bilingual and it has to be English and
French, but some for some reason in West Coast, we don't
give a fuck.
Like, yeah, in West Coast, we don't really follow the rules
of the bilingual stuff.
We're like English.
Like, you barely hear, we're so far from the East Coast
side.
So because we're so far from there, we're just like English.
Like, what are you going to do?
from you guys.
What are they gonna do?
So majority of people in the West Coast just speaks English
and don't do the bilingual stuff.
So I barely ever hear like French being spoken here, even
though like technically, cause like if you're in the East
Coast, a lot of the signs and everything and like messages
and stuff, they have to do the bilingual stuff.
And it has like some signs are like, French or like they are
in French and English, but here we're like, sometimes,
sometimes in specific places in the West Coast, it's Chinese
and English.
In some places in the West Coast, we're like, we just got
rid of the French and just be like Chinese and English
signs.
Like, yeah.
Like we're like second language is French, no.
patroesu thank you super chat thank you thank you you can
call them kevin kwa they probably aren't listening um next
thing thank you super chat thank you thank you uh lord
carosa thank you super chat thank you thank you eyes full of
whimsy and deception somber thank you for the akasupa thank
you thank you i am late and incredible excited for this i
never expected armor court 60 exists resign to series ending
with verdict day only to be surprised a decade later that
was a good day i do hope you enjoy and i look forward to
seeing your design philosophy oh yeah people are telling me
that i can design my own mech i'm so bad at doing like
customization but we'll see what i come up with uh but thank
you for the akasupa somber thank you thank you yes i'm super
excited too uh um make sure to thank your fellow dragons
your fellow member goons for picking uh today's uh game for
us today we're like we gotta start a new series and um um
your fellow member goons picked armor core unanimously they
unionized just to pick today's game uh all right let's
actually play it oh let's go armor core i'm ready
oh let's see how it goes actually i'm i don't know what i'm
gonna make I need to know what options I have.
Alright,
let's see.
Riding game is booting up.
I need to put it on the screen.
Armored core.
Alright.
Well, why is it?
Why is it like...
What the fuck?
Why does it seem like there's a filter on top of it?
that's weird why is it so dark oh what it doesn't look like
that it i swear to god it does not look like that oh is that
the hdr okay i might have to it might be the hdr oh yeah 100
is the hdr i tap back into the game and it's like all right
i got yes i was like it does not look that dark on my all
right information oh understand all right let's get rid of
hdr uh oh yeah that's what it was i was like why is it like
so doll colored uh annie thank you for the magenta soup but
thank you thank you i'll do borderless window just so i can
tap in and out uh thank you for the magenta soup 621
absolute favorite of mine i hope you like it armor core 6
came out about three years ago so hopefully a new armor core
game coming out uh next year and then the magenta sofa then
you thank you i feel like if it did really well i'm pretty
sure they're gonna make more they always do let me 120 i
don't even know if my pc can handle 120 but we're gonna do
that okay this is also why we're capping today's stream my
voice is
strained right now but I'll take some rest uh after today um
I'm gonna try not to do too long streams after uh for next
week just because I need my voice to rest it's very well
opt-in that's good to know I'll put it on medium still just
in case because I don't trust myself I'll trust myself or my
PC on the left is very barely visible sound guy get red i
i'm gonna assume i'm gonna put voice at nine right off the
bat just because like um it's always the voice acting that's
uh that's like you can barely hear matchmaking global fuck
it
real i'm not dokey bird
We'll never know if she's real or not.
We're close to Rubicon.
Activating cerebral coral control device.
Augmented human.
C4-621 has awakened.
Time to get to work 621.
Oh my god, he said the line!
I'm powering down your entry capsule.
On my signal.
He said it!
Activate the AC.
Dad is cheering us on.
He's like, we got this!
We got this not Doki Bird!
Oh shit.
We're breaching the perimeter?
...
And Goddy turned on the AC, guys.
It seemed like it was getting really hot, yeah.
Don't worry, I got my visa.
I'm legally allowed to be here.
I'm the Space Federation.
I got my visa approved, guys.
Do not worry.
I'm so naked.
It washed off the paint!
My customization!
Off target, but within permissible range.
Wow!
My years of customization, God!
Yeah, I gave myself the visa to legally be allowed to be
here.
Oh my god, what the?
Okay, we got to adjust the sense.
I knew I forgot something.
Okay, the sense was the first thing I should have adjusted.
Uh, is it camera settings or is it?
Would it be camera controls?
actually oh there we go it's mouse sensitivity yeah there
you go all right and i immediately started blasting okay
there's movement and then all right and then tab is boost
movement on Why is...
Why is Tab me?
Why press Tab?
But why Tab?
What does Tab do?
It doesn't seem like it changes anything.
Does it actually... Oh!
Never mind, I see it now.
I just realized I've just asked him a tapping Tab for a
while.
Never mind, I see it.
I was like, it doesn't seem like...
I don't have any...
Okay, I do have a sprint meter.
Okay, I do see it.
I do have an energy meter.
Wait, it's just shift.
Oh, wait, actually, no.
Okay, I'm just playing around with the controls right now.
I gotta get used to it because I go so fast.
I'm speeding through everything.
So I do have a dash.
I learned that before I learned anything else.
Yeah.
Okay, there it is.
all right there was stamina bar okay some energy stable
would replenish his rapidly went on and around that's good
oh it replenishes so fucking fast yeah it's so fast I zoomed
so fucking fast rapid fire right hand okay clear out this
guard mix perfect chance to test her and see a right click
is Boom!
Sword attack.
Okay.
Target assist.
E used right shoulder.
Use left hand.
Okay, there's E.
There's a target assist.
Okay.
Okay, that's the missile.
Alright.
So I also have a missile attack.
That is very zoomed.
It goes so fast.
Thank you for assist thank you taxpayer the missile launch
equipped to the right shoulder is capable of multi-lock oh
so I just have to hold e that's good to know boom that's
right thank you taxpayers for your missiles all right access
use repair kits to repair your AC and recover AP.
Not anymore.
Whoops.
Alright.
Access the catapult.
Oh.
There's the catapult.
I missed it.
Oh, I did.
I like went past it.
I was like, I don't need to use the catapult.
I'll just run across
Let's go It's like I'll make my own catapult With my own
body
Time to fly 6-2-1 Yay
Wee If we get our hands on Robocon
Buy their life back Oh, what?
Am I?
Are we the bad guys?
No.
Million dollar corporation will do no Let's see.
Surely not.
We're illegals here.
You'll need ID to operate.
Oh, shit.
Um.
I am...
You know when he said we're illegals?
Um.
He was just joking, guys.
He was joking.
Quick boots let's instantly accelerate.
In any direction.
Help me evade attack.
Guys, guys.
I am legally...
on this territory.
Guys, guys.
No, no, no, guys.
Legally, I'm supposed to be here.
Guys.
Guys, guys, he was just joking.
He was misspoke, guys.
I'm definitely new here legally.
See, there are the illegals.
I'm here policing the area.
See, he was talking about these guys.
guys chat you're talking about them not me okay assault
boost press s
i'm that's right get out of here you're not supposed to be
here
I'm helping They didn't have a visa So I'm patrolling the
area Guys Like a good citizen
See I have a visa
Check my credentials No No no no I'm the native here This is
my land That's sad.
Now.
That's the PCA's planet side force.
Oh shit.
Keep a low profile.
We don't want them breathing down our necks.
Yep.
Don't worry, they won't know I'm here.
They won't know.
Check out my visa.
Show sword.
Do you have your credentials?
Yeah, dude.
Check this out.
Yeah, I'm the native now.
Oh, there it is.
Extract the pilot data.
I'll analyze it.
What the fuck?
What are you guys doing here?
Do you have your visa?
Don't worry.
All right, license code extracted from the AC wreck in the
contaminated city contains the pilot's registration data.
Registration number RB.
All right, Ms. Bob, shock infinity gambit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right, your shield ain't gonna block this.
Bam!
That's right, block this visa.
We have invasive species right now.
This is my new home.
Dang, it expired.
That's right.
It sucks, guys.
Their visa expired.
It's like a card game.
Whichever visa is biggest wins.
Application denied.
It's like a card game, guys.
My visa is bigger, so eliminated their visa.
Ow.
I accidentally hit myself.
Wait, how do I heal again?
It was alright.
see am i though i am
boom there we go holy there's so many
easy he's his kills on my left all right it's out all of
them where are the others oh there's still hitting that's
right my v's is bigger holy
shit i'm moving everywhere i'm zooming are they all dead oh
they're all dead hello oh i didn't even realize i have ammo
license code extracted from an ac wreck in the contaminated
city contains the pilots registration data registration
number rb37 license expires in 15 days well my license now
it's still valid but the pilots rank is no good oh we can't
never mind we can't use this head to the next wreck oh that
goes that one of course it's always the last wreck every
time wait wait what do you mean 30% what do you mean we're
not Private, but we're private, though.
I should have unlimited money.
Oh my god, no.
The shareholders.
They're cutting my branch.
They're cutting my budget.
License code extracted from AC, wreck, and contaminate the
city.
My stocks.
I'm about to get laid off.
License expires in 12 hours.
That's everything.
One more.
Oh, wow.
All right, of course.
Where is it?
I can't kill you.
I'm running out of money.
It took my budget.
Oh, it's over there.
All right.
I'll head over this way.
Wait, if I use sword, does that consume my ammo?
While standing on a vertical catapult perform a jump to
quickly reach high up places.
Wee.
Okay.
That's it.
Try accessing the wreck.
all right hello guys i'm gonna access the wreck now
accessing accessing downloading registration number rb23
rank fits the bill call sign what what oh my god what's that
oh shit looks like they were on to you after all How do they
know?
But I have a visa!
But it doesn't matter.
I don't understand!
Oh shit.
I'm trying to...
Oh no!
Heal, heal, heal, Oh my god, keep accidentally pressing left
click.
He got a bigger visa.
It's a bigger number.
There's no way I can win!
Like, what?
I'm jiggle peeking, I'm jiggle peeking, I'm jiggle peeking
them.
Wait, I didn't even know he was doing explosions on the
ground.
Validate your visa.
Holy shit!
much I'm like trying so hard to get close to him I want to
use my knife oh no
boom boom boom did I make a cap wait what did I do oh I
should press control I didn't know time to lose that no okay
okay i did it i know i'll play this now all right helicopter
beats mech all right get it now all right
that's it try accessing the wreck oh i have to do this i've
accessed the mech again all right give me access to this i'm
ready failed the interview but but i have a visa
oh my god
knife get knife oh my god i'm trying to get knife get knifed
I'm trying to dodge as much as I can.
Get knifed!
I told you I can learn!
I'm getting fucked up, but I told you I can learn!
Get knifed!
That's fucking right!
I got you!
Boom!
Alright, I figured it out.
out i downloaded it guys i copied it out i copy this move
sets i'm a learning ai
nice try that's all for our work here look at that look at
that i learned his move sets
that's working right independent license expires in three
days I can learn you all told me but I can learn dokey GPT
that's your new name here on Rubicon that's my new name I'm
Raven alright that was a filter What if I told this boss
usually takes people a lot more than two wait, really?
See guys, I passed my interview.
I verified my visa.
Look at that, guys.
I told you I have a visa.
My visa passed verification.
Coral, a sublime substance.
Discovered on Rubicon, a planet.
on the frontier of developed space for a time coral was a
revolutionary energy resource and data conduit i got the
green card transform human society by leaps and bounds guys
we don't look at the cost screen don't worry i'll get
sponsors yes anyone want to sponsor my the next ammo drop.
And...
Oral, the kindling was thought to have been utterly consumed
forever lost.
Yeah.
Oh, we're ending here for their natural resources, right?
Embers continued to burn.
Humanity would inevitably return.
Oh, do you guys want more volume?
Up and more.
To stoke the fire.
Wait, sound guy.
What is your... Oh, bring master...
Okay, wait, I just see it.
Alright.
I bring master volume up to 8.
Okay.
Registration number.
I just saw it.
I was too busy.
Verify...
Yeah, I should verify my volume.
I'm Raven now.
I found my visa, guys.
This is Allmind.
The mercenary support system.
Welcome back, Raven.
That's me.
Welcome back.
Guys, I just lost my visa and I found it.
I found my passport.
I've picked up some work for you already.
Take a look, 621.
Guys, I had my visa, but I lost my passport in the ruins.
I'm glad I found it, guys.
This notification follows Restoral of Access Privileges.
Allmind provides a combat training simulator to support its
mercenaries.
Your license was in a suspended state.
found my passport guys as an added incentive completion of
the exercises will be rewarded with ac parts you stand to
benefit regardless mm-hmm yeah well it is now available
sortie sortie ac design oh i can design my ac now all right
oh customize your ac assemblies using the parts you have
available at the assembly menu when available when assembly
and AC ensure that your builds keeps within the maximum wave
and EN load perimeters wait what's the maximum weight oh
wait let's put decals on apply emblems in your possession
user-created images to decal what do you mean user-created
how do I even get that oh image editor oh Wait, is there,
save and load, in order to load, you must complete on all
the parts.
If you're online, you can upload assemblies.
How do I, I want to download people's assemblies?
Wait.
Has anyone made a dragon yet?
Has anyone, there was a custom decal?
How do I get there?
Paint.
Okay.
Let's do assembly.
I don't know how to assemble this.
Wait, actually?
Oh, I don't have anything.
That's all I have?
I can only... Oh, I can only customize paint and nothing
else.
Let's see.
Indeed.
Alright, let's just make it yellow.
Military.
Where's... I'll just make it yellow.
Pattern.
Oh, wait, camo!
Oh my god, zebra print!
There's no way they can see me.
I'll blend right in.
How would they know?
Guys, how would they know?
Do I can only use the air?
They'll never know.
I'll blend right in.
right in
mega dragon but they'll never know if i'm camouflaged in
just i'm like the sun i think i'm like the sun hey i like
that it'll keep that and then we'll be like
oh is there select all parts Yeah, how do I do that?
Wait, all...
Oh, entire frame.
There we go.
Wait, what the fuck?
How do I do all colors?
I want all of them to be this color.
It's not the piss bot.
It's the goon bot.
It's the...
It's scratch.
It's the dragoon bot.
Guys.
Oh, there we go.
Entire frame.
Please be this color.
I want it to be this color.
Yes!
Do I make it so that everybody will follow my current color?
You have to remake it?
You have to remake the thing for it to be the entire bot.
Oh, I can save the pattern?
How do I save it?
I want to save this beautiful pattern I made.
how do i save it guys it doesn't tell me it's a beautiful
pattern i want to keep on all of my the code for symbol
dragon decal main h c z z c n all right we'll see that i go
to color set yeah i'm at color set
press v Oh, color set Change the user Oh my god, there it is
Did I do it?
I didn't even realize there were more
Paste Yes Oh, never mind Oh, go back to color set How do I
copy my pattern?
How do I copy it?
Why is my pad?
You're still on...
Oh, wait.
Send in the goon butt.
How do I cop?
Oh, my God.
It's like me as a grandmother again.
I'm like a granny again.
Before pacing.
Got a cop.
Go to the far left tab.
How do I use Facebook?
Facebook.
To me, I accidentally opened the camera.
It's facing me right now.
What do I do?
I took 20 pictures of my face.
I wanted to message you about my cute, about my new teapot I
bought.
Push F.
Granny, please.
Where?
Where do I push F to me?
Where do I push F?
Oh no.
Now they're telling me to put in my, put in my username and
link my Dear to God, I don't know where I am, Timmy.
Where am I?
Wait, I don't want this color.
How did I get that color?
How did I get this chair?
Where did that color came from?
Why does it keep facing this color?
Why does it, Timmy?
I keep trying to copy, but it keeps pasting this color to
me.
That's not the color I picked.
Grab a step away from the keyboard.
Step away.
Go to pattern.
Okay, press F.
Okay.
I'm pressing F.
I'm pulling my...
Oh, yay!
Confirm.
We did it.
This is a beautiful robot.
Welcome to...
Let's... Yay!
We did it.
We taught... You guys taught me how to do it.
We did it, Grandma.
Where did it go?
This is... Yay!
We're looking at holy pit ray kill that is this killing the
pit ray right now is it It's where is it where is the bot
where is the robot All this work it's beautiful wait no we
don't want to get rid of that that's Beautiful, I love it.
There we go.
Save edits.
Okay, wait, wait, someone has...
Alright.
Download.
Okay, where's that decal?
The bitrate found it.
Alright.
My grandma did it.
Where is this?
Wait, no, no code exists.
What are you talking about?
This code doesn't even exist.
Okay, wait.
We have to, I just realized I forgot to do the weapons.
Where's the weapons?
That not?
Oh, there it is.
Uh, paint.
Okay, don't worry.
I know how to do it now.
Wait, how do I do it?
Why is it home?
Timmy!
Timmy, why is it still on this one?
Where's my pattern?
I designed the pattern!
No, no.
Timmy, Timmy, I know what website I'm on.
I wanted to buy you a birthday present on the HTTPP.
Yes, slash, the colon, slash, slash, Amazon.com to me.
Now I'm on some crazy website.
There's booms everywhere.
But what do I do?
There's booms to me.
There's booms everywhere.
Please.
No, that's a lie.
Do I click it?
It tells me I won $500 to it.
me they said i won 500 oh i did it guys i figured it out yes
i did it i figured it out yes okay uh where where is it
where did it go I copied it!
But I copied it!
Where did it go?
Where did it save your work in AC data?
Units F again.
Oh, okay, I get it.
I got it, I got it.
I have an idea.
Alright, there it is.
And then...
all units pattern wait color set why does it keep doing that
color I don't understand
where's my pattern oh wait wait I have an idea though I have
an idea guys I have an idea I know what I you know what it
doesn't need to be we have to make a different camera oh my
god wait wait i can make it super shiny yeah wait and then
uh pat weathering okay my eyes is this what a stroke is
i'm doing it.
I'm figuring it out, guys.
Okay, we'll have camo, too.
Fresh out the factory.
Oh my god, we had flames on it.
It's gonna be so cool, guys.
Oh my god.
That's when we're going to go so fast.
Wait.
Wait, wait.
I know.
Oh my god.
It makes the gunfire faster, chat.
It...
guys the fire it makes it fire faster
oh the the piss guns three times faster exactly exactly yeah
you get it you get it the flames the flame stickers the
flame stickers makes the gun go faster you know make the
speedy bullets look there's plane patterns on it catch up at
last day there you go i did it our decals all right how do
we import decals guys is it ac data no that's ac oh it's
image editor combined preset to create images if online
you're gonna oh here we go all right download it there you
go oh hey Zen oh wait that's so cool all right let's get
that in oh my god wait oh I deleted it oh we know I did it
okay decals does it come in wait where did it go wait where
did it go how do I down how do I keep it
How do I use it in decals?
That's so cute!
That's a little dragon!
Oh, no, it's time again!
The grandma!
We gotta figure out the sound.
Oh, there it is!
Yay!
Wait, where did it go?
Where is it?
Oh, it's right.
It's so small.
What the fuck?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's so fucking small.
Let's add it.
I keep forgetting there's more to this menu.
Let's essentially, let's put it on the yeah, that's right.
Let's put it on the head and the chest.
It hit it in the camo.
All right, we're gonna put some sponsors in here.
Wait, I need to do an image editor.
How do I...
Okay.
Oh, I can only use shapes.
I can't use...
Oh, I was gonna write something.
I can't use letters.
Oh, my God.
There's flames.
Oh, wait, I can!
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Grandma.
Grandma's trying to figure this out, kids.
What do you mean?
Okay,
bye.
I will.
I will use my letters.
Maybe you should change your camel color.
Why?
I think it looks great.
I could barely see the robot.
Wait, can I change the color of these?
I cannot.
I'm committed to it.
the white I'm committed to this color okay or maybe maybe
we'll do it we'll change it to red halfway maybe red will be
more visible actually now that I think about it it's like a
serial killer shit too
I'm learning a serial killer note, ransom note right now,
guys.
What?
Yeah.
All right.
There we go.
And then...
And then we gotta grab E.
E.
all right we're almost done guys in before i accidentally
close the decal segment what is grandma doing yeah it's
pretty much a logo creator what a mech game attached to it i
saw some insane emblems hi hi this thank you super chat
thank you thank you guys it's fine it's gonna look great
guys I will shim I will shim my merch And you will be able
to read it Oh shit We're gonna put Dar here Cause I realize
I'm running out of space I'm running out of grab a shim Guys
guys Can you please buy my Tupperware They said I can go I
can level up to Level 8 Level 8 mage.
If I sell 20 Tupperware, guys.
I just need to recruit three more people.
They say it's not a pyramid scheme, dragons.
And I'm a value member in their community.
There we go.
It should be done.
How do I save it?
Okay.
I gotta make sure I save this.
How do I...
done?
I'm done.
How do I save?
Do I have a life?
I'm keeping it funny.
I said too much time.
Buy my merch.
Job is done.
Job done, guys.
Job done.
okay save and quit there you go by my merch yay okay decal
let's put on my legs where is it there you go
right there all right where would this go actually oh i can
oh wait what I could just plaster this everywhere.
Buy my merch.
There you go.
Okay, can I make it bigger?
How do I make this bigger?
Okay,
we're gonna make this.
Actually, fuck this one.
This one I fucked up.
I don't know how to make it bigger.
I... Toki, no.
The trash.
We're putting ads!
We're putting ads on this mech!
This mech is sponsored by Tokey Bird.
That's right!
Ads everywhere!
On the crunch!
Oh, wait.
There we go.
It's like a NASCAR.
It is.
I want to know how to put on the backside.
There's premium.
There's premium space.
Every fight is going to be a mercy kill.
So they have to see this anymore.
Thank you for the super chat.
Next scene.
Thank you.
I'm like, guys, guys, how do I put in this butt, on his
butt, like a stamp, like a tramp stamp, guys.
This is very important information.
What do you mean, ugly?
He's camo, and he's sponsored.
My mech is sponsored, guys.
It's a NASCAR.
I need to turn it around.
I need it up on the butt so people will know to buy my
merch.
Okay.
Can't put in the back.
They did not go to this side.
How do I rotate you?
Oh, I can rotate it on the screen?
I can?
How can it be careful?
So it's like a floating sticker.
So when they see it when they see it they'll be like whoa i
buy my merch this will help you sell the stock shirts you
have unless not the sponsored womb tattoo bro cast they even
super chat thank you thank you oh okay okay i get it i know
what to do okay all right Oh my god.
If I die.
No.
Just remember.
By my birth.
By my...
It's like the Andy thing.
Jockey, please.
And then...
Okay, wait.
Right here.
Okay.
Just so you all know.
Right here.
That last thing you'll ever see.
And then...
Alright, where do we put that?
Maybe, like, right...
Right here.
It's free real estate.
there you go
there you go we got the tramp stamp too guys anyone want to
sponsor anything on my mech guys i'm selling ad space right
now but don't give your if your profile is invisible with
that perfect camel how would they know whose merch to buy
guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
they'll know guys they'll know i only see is the profit
colored cap yeah thank you super chat thank you thank you
yeah guys i'm selling premium ad space right now anyone want
anything on there there we go just the bottom half though
the top half is the top half is reserved for dragoon and
cavo it's called subliminal messaging exactly exactly The
NASCAR bot.
Not on the P-colored dokey.
What are you doing?
They're like, what does that say?
And because it's small, they'll want to get, like, closer.
So they'll be like, oh my God, what does that say?
So they'll get closer and be like, oh, Obama, Mercer, they
want to get close to me.
Like, I put the new Fridays on the Jeep.
Nero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's subliminal messaging, guys.
Alright.
Going once.
Going twice.
Come on.
There's premium ad space right now.
You can put anything on there.
I want to buy a couple boot stamps on the chest area.
Guys, thank you for the magenta soup.
But thank you.
Thank you.
to Gus.
All right.
Let's see.
Don't worry.
I know what to do.
All right.
I told you.
I feel inexplicable in sudden desire to buy Doki merch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's all right.
It's too late.
The offer's gone.
The Gus.
Let's see.
It's too late.
Alright, this is a perfect one, too.
Whoops.
Where's my preset?
For it.
Alright, we'll grab that.
What color, Gus?
You know what?
It should be green.
Alright.
Green boobs.
As it should.
Oh, shit.
I mean, I had to copy that anyway.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Confirm.
here confirm and then we need a zero we'll take that that oh
wait actually
all right confirm how do i copy this oh copy there
and then we're gonna make this one a little tinier
and and then get that five in
there we go perfect thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you delete this why this is beautiful I'm selling ad
space I'm just selling ad space guys what's wrong with that
oh I'm not allowed I'm not allowed to make wait we're is it
okay where is it so i'm not allowed to
to make make an honest days work that's fantastic just
trying to make a living guys Think of my family here.
Alright, nice.
We're good.
Oh, I should actually adjust that sticker.
Wait.
We'll make it purple.
Sponsored.
Give me a sec, guys.
Okay.
We gotta add on to it.
Sponsored.
Wait, where's the hashtag?
People will know.
So people will know it's sponsored, guys.
I don't want to get in trouble with the ad company.
I don't want to get in trouble with the law.
Post has to be like People have to know A post is sponsored
Or I'll get in trouble
Guys I don't want to be in trouble With the law With the FTC
Close on What does 20 get me?
Thank you Super Chat Thank you Thank you Super Thank you
Super Chat Thank you Thank you Normal AC fans Cool to have
the new fashion court To create the coolest looking mix.
Meanwhile, GigaBring to Tokyo.
Did I hear free ad placements?
Guys, I don't want to get into trouble, yes.
I don't want the FTC to be on my ass, guys.
They have to know.
Hashtag sponsor.
Sponsor.
Where's the R?
There we go.
Done.
Look at that.
Beautiful.
I think that works.
Sponsor.
Oh, I should add E.
E.
D.
There we go.
It's beautiful.
Is it do I have to re-edit that?
I think I might have to.
Oh, I do.
Okay.
That's fine.
Change decal.
You can sort of see it.
It's sort of there.
Oh, but that being there is so good, though.
But that being there is so good.
wait I couldn't move the sponsor part it's all right you can
sort of see it ah that works for me that works for me it's
just covered up a little bit it's all right okay we're done
I think it's I think it's complete I hope this share code is
for steam elf out what's that share code raptor thank you
for the thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
it's not all all right guys i think we're done i think we're
i think this beautiful mech is done sort sarty our hone your
skills what do i do now did i finish the game oh wait i
forgot about my emblem how do i get rid of my emblem
Oh, wait, that's my raven emblem.
I can't get rid of it.
Did I save it?
Oh, I save it.
Hey, you see data and save?
See.
It's beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
Hashtag hashtag.
Of course.
Oh, that's true.
Wait.
It's hashtag sponsored goon bot.
Husky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki is the guy driving the van.
Written in advertisement.
Written in Barker.
It's those cars where it's like, um, car is for sale.
Please, please call.
Please call this number.
How do I change the emblem, guys?
I want to change the emblem.
Or is that forever?
Is the emblem forever?
Wash me.
Oh, hit F.
Oh, it.
Not Doki Bird.
Alright, edit emblem.
Okay.
There's my emblem.
Buy my merch.
Alright.
Do we just progress?
Do we just do missions?
I guess that's it.
Very fitting.
Destroy all of them.
Alright, let's see.
That's an emblem.
Destroy all of Rubicon.
Liberation.
Liberation front.
Alright, progress the story.
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
We got a hustle.
This is an open call from the Balaam group.
One of the corporate forces occupying Rubicon.
Attention all independent mercenaries.
That's me.
This request comes from our affiliate, Duffong.
The Rubicon Liberation Front has deployed Bouse artillery
throughout the continuum.
Wait, there's more to this game?
I know, right?
What do you mean there's more?
We cannot allow them to hinder expansion of the Coral
Survey.
Show us your ambition.
Destroy the Liberation Front's artillery.
Bonus pay will be awarded for destroying their MTs.
You want the enemy weakened.
Consider it an opportunity to prove yourself.
Impress us mercenaries!
Alright.
I'm ready.
Search neon yes please where's my robot i can't see as long
as it gets done guys where is it like where is he guys
where's the robot i can't see it it's god
main system activating combat mode
Perfectly blended in.
Oh, my God.
I could barely see it.
All right.
Slash!
Oh, no longer slash.
Are you still dead?
It has...
My gun has flame stickers on it.
You won't understand.
That's one of the artillery placements.
The front is protected.
Armor cleaning.
Deploy the combat.
Destroy that AC.
Boom!
Easy.
That's our get out of here.
My money is not worth your time I'm going so zoom What is
this way It has flame stickers on so my bullets go faster
I'm gonna try
That's right I am
Slash All right, that should be the last one.
Oh, the final site.
Oh, it's over there.
Man, it's just easy baby stuff.
Yeah, flame stickers on guns increase the fire rate.
Guys, it's simple maths.
Simple engineering.
All right, let's go over.
Oh my god.
I'm like, sometimes I get lost, you know?
You're like, where did the mech go?
You know?
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Wait, it hit me?
That's impossible!
How did it hit me?
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Slash!
Alright.
There we go.
We're done.
We're done here.
Turn to base.
Where's my base?
Is that it?
Yeah!
Yeah, that's right.
Couldn't even see me.
Look at that.
I only used the $15,000.
Still got paid up.
Still got paid.
efficiency here look we got profit one new message oh
this is a notification from all mind the mercenary support
system registration number rb23 call sign raven your return
to mercenary activities has been acknowledged restoring
access to the parts shop
all right part shop oh i have a shop now i have new exercise
data added all right i am by what can i buy sold by various
corporations and factions from the buy menu more pots are
available to purchase as you progress through the story oh
which one is the best gun though
which one makes me look cooler wait how much money do i oh i
have so much money okay it does increase the weight the huge
rifle but look at my head well you can't really see it I
know it's hard to see my head because it's invisible which
one's better all of them at the fine and the best gun at the
yeah which one makes the biggest bang bang sound guys
I need to know which one goes bang bang bigger.
The bazooka?
Oh, we'll grab the bazooka.
Which one though?
Which size should use the bazooka?
Should it be the...
Should it be the left arm or the right arm?
Which one?
You're looking at.
Dad's looking at me.
both dual wield oh my god all right you're right what if i
dual wield it okay but imagine what if i would that be bad
guys would dual wielding be bad even even wait which one has
the sword I don't even know.
Oh, wait.
Wait, is that... There's a sword on my other hand?
That's kind of bad.
Oh, try and see.
Let's do it.
I believe.
I believe in the dual wheel design.
Alright.
Where is it?
Okay.
Where's my...
Here we go.
Is that the sword?
Oh, don't worry with the flame prints guys with the flame
prints I go so guys it's gonna the bazooka is gonna go so
fast Apparently training gives me free items so it's like
pragmata right And complete the exercise using the ace
training ac All right beginner did I just did I just do this
one Sure I'll do the training again
All right Watch this, guys.
Target and Rapid Fire.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, I forgot to equip it.
That's right.
Slashy slash.
Or does it give me like...
Or does it give me like established stuff?
R to manually reload my...
Oh.
Oh, it's not mine.
Oh, I...
I can't test my cool ass.
My double bazooka.
Can use missiles.
Use hold to...
Okay, I knew that.
Alright.
Get over here.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
What?
I hold it.
There we go.
Now.
Oh, never mind.
Guess not.
Oh, it's because I was reloading.
It's okay.
I successfully did my training.
It counts.
Okay.
Left, left.
Oh, I can chain attacks.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Whoops.
Reloading.
Give me a sec.
I'm...
Just reloading my hand real quick.
You know, just the usual.
Alright.
here i could detect enemies no wonder this is tutorial
that's looking right you thought you could hide from me he
was so polite i was like whoops guys sorry yeah that should
hit all of them
oh wait what oh i didn't detect him apparently pew pew pew
pew pew pew
Training simulation?
Done.
Pass with flying colors.
Oh, it shows hidden chest.
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright.
Where is AC test?
Okay, I want to know what it's like.
The double bazooka.
Okay, use the AC test.
Yeah, you know what?
Yeah, I think we can make it work, guys.
Look at that.
The 1-2.
The double booms.
See?
The flame stickers are making it go so fast.
Wait, I can add more.
Wait, I just realized.
Bing, Bing.
Spawn a target?
Alright.
How do I spawn a target?
How do I spawn it?
Bing.
Big damage, guys.
Don't worry, I'll hit every shot.
Two big booms.
How do I spawn him?
Is that?
I told you I spawn!
Fuck!
Let's go back to the garage.
I just love too many people started shooting me.
Wait, wait, I have an idea.
Where am I?
Wait, can I...
No, wait, I can't put decals on my guns?
What's the point?
If I can't put...
I was going to add more flames.
I was going to add more flame stickers to my fucking gun.
Bro, gotcha.
I can't believe...
I can't make my gun go faster.
What's the point?
To all independent mercenaries.
This request comes from Schneider of the Archivist Group.
The operation will take place in Grid 135, Southern Belius.
Your objective is to destroy an MT squad sent by Daphon in
Balaam Company.
How dare...
This is my turf.
We've got dibs.
...foothold in Archivist's efforts to conduct a coral survey
in the contaminated city.
You, the independent mercenaries, are the key to maintaining
our lead in the coral survey race.
this group looks forward to news of your success how dare
they this is my turf i was here first yeah i'm ready i'm
ready for the double booms you've got a day now you need a
rep get the retention six two one there we go i'm an
independent contractor i go where the money takes me and i
have no benefits I have no insurance whatsoever.
Get me access.
I'm here to wipe them out.
Add my double booms.
Boom!
At least they didn't send the best version.
that's fucking right easy where are they boom oh shit what
the fuck what boomed me get out of here that's
fine boom only slightly overkill there's no such thing as
overkill that bird's turned through us
targets left well i need to reload my missiles give me a sec
There we go.
And then one left.
Where are these guys?
Huh?
It doesn't matter because they'll be dead soon!
That's fucking right.
It doesn't matter who they are.
There we go.
What?
Reinforcements.
You mean dead enforcements.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, I said it.
Gotta send an actual army if you want to kill me.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Got him.
The enemy MT squad has been eliminated.
My two big booms will get that problem.
There we go.
Look at that.
Mission complete.
Daddy ate slack joke.
Look, I only spent $12,000.
Job done.
See, 12K.
Not too shabby.
Wait, I could kick enemies?
How?
Wait, that must actually be good.
because I don't have to waste my ammo.
Registration number RB23.
Call sign.
Raven.
Your records have been updated.
You have also been granted access to participate in the
Loghunt program.
We kindly request that you submit combat logs after
destroying designated left.
I've done lock kicking.
All mine will reward you with parts based on the number of
submissions you provide.
Alright.
Seems fine.
You're invited to join Loghunt out on a...
All Mights, mercenaries, support.
Oh my god!
I gotta join the community!
Let's go over and destroy targets marked with the log hunt
target icon to obtain combat logs or submissions.
Collect combat logs and prove your hunter class to receive
reward parts from all mine.
Look at that!
It's like a training group.
Look at that.
So nice.
Alright, we have another training group.
training test fundamentals a bounty hunter program how nice
of them they established a program just for us all right
target right hand hood I mean didn't we learn that already
damn
oh oh is that sniper wait that that's fire um hold and then
use okay
training stagger are treated as direct hits and deal more
damage use yo oh yeah we learned about that
yeah and then one two easy the good old one two oh whoops
That's awkward.
Alright.
Use E.
I know how to do that.
We're learning that already.
Well, it takes a while because it takes so long.
I am using it.
I'm reloading.
Oh, fuck this.
Fuck that.
There we go.
Can't be bothered.
Wait, what do you mean?
It just told me to use E.
Yeah, but it took so long to build.
The stagger took so long.
With, like, greater ACS strain than usual.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Greetings, lap dog.
This is old king.
We're going to destroy creative old three.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Nice.
We staggered him.
Oh.
How did I miss?
Boom.
Nice stagger.
Yeah.
all right shields equipped to the left shoulder can be
deployed to reduce incoming damage oh i have a shield oh my
god i do wait when did i have a shield i forgot a cue attack
what if i quit one did i have do i have a do i have a a cue
Oh, do I have a queue on my other mech?
I don't even remember what my queue was.
What was my queue on my other mech?
No?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I just need to equip something.
Okay, blocking during this.
Shield output is maximized for one to two seconds after
deployment.
There you go.
That's right.
this boom that's right i just realized he's doing damage to
me what the fuck easy uh rush small arms that can be used
during movement with like oh okay control
Slash!
Oh, nice.
And then...
Oh, I used up all my brush now.
That's awkward.
Oops.
That's alright.
Simulation complete.
There you go.
Now I know how to use the assault boost.
Yay!
Alright, can I...
Does that mean I can equip the...
Which one is my key?
Oh, Here it is.
Oh, I do have nothing.
I guess I'll buy it.
Oh, sorry.
My handyman was going to fix my cabinet.
They were there to...
They had to put, like, extra wood or something in the holes.
Like, fix the holes.
And they had to dry.
So today he's coming back to actually put the cabinet onto
the thing.
So he's going to be here in 10 minutes.
So that means I have to end...
I have 10 minutes to...
do one more mission all right the sad 10-minute mission that
i can do this oh i forgot to put more parts fuck
i'm having fun this is fun though this game is really fun i
know i wish i could do a longer stream guys i really do but
i do also have a meet and greet later today so i'll make
sure i have enough voice power for later today counter
guerrilla resistance from bouse mass produce mts they're no
great concern you performed adequately in your last swordy
raven this did not go unnoticed we will be watching with
interest to see what you bring to the team all right
all right let's see assembly i don't have anything though i
didn't buy anything i didn't buy new missiles i spent all my
monies on two big booms
oh my god they know i'm climbing the ranks my agent is so
proud of me he's so proud of me right now He's like, oh my
god, I'm gonna be a star!
Main system, activating combat mode.
What me ugly?
You just can't see him.
That's why.
Destroy the Rubicon Liberation Front Transport Choppers.
We're under attack.
You think it's ugly just because you can't see him.
Keep them off the supply.
Affirmed.
Transport Chopper down.
Keep at it.
How do you even know it's ugly?
If you can't see the mech, guys.
That's right.
I'm going to straight for it.
Defend it.
Nice defense, losers.
Yeah, you guys don't even matter to me.
Nice defense.
Boom.
Boom!
Defend what?
Exactly.
I'll tell you they've got a bouse tetrapod.
Does it count above the other MTs?
Ignore it and focus on the mission.
Boom!
Looks like you got them all.
Fucking easy.
Don't worry.
We have a big ass mech.
They say as I drive past it.
Look at that.
Return to base.
Where's the cat protection?
Yeah.
See, they couldn't see me.
Only 8K this time.
Look at that.
Just like the simulation.
Pros skip the fight.
Why fight where I could just walk around?
me.
Wait, I ignored a bunch of bonus money.
Wait, it was bonus money?
No!
I just forgot from my life.
Guys, it's not my fault.
He couldn't see me.
Wait, can I redo it?
Can I redo it?
Can I get my money back?
Yes.
All right.
Can I get more money if I redo it?
Let me buy it real quick.
I need to buy my...
Wait, which one doesn't have?
Which one doesn't have it?
Was it my left or my right?
Does everyone remember?
I don't remember.
Uh.
Is it my left side or my right side?
I didn't have a gun.
Because I don't remember.
It was my left?
Okay.
That's a shield.
That's a...
Oh my god!
What if two missiles?
Yes.
Alright.
I'm ready to redo that.
This time I'll fight him for real.
Oh my god.
Two missiles.
Alright.
All right, last mission.
Now I'll kill him.
Now I'll actually kill him.
All right.
LG for real.
That's right.
Two missiles.
Oh my god.
Look at all these missiles on my back.
Look at all these missiles.
And then two missiles.
Oh wait.
I fucked it up.
Boom!
Get out of here.
I'm meeting.
What do you mean I didn't quit both?
Boom!
Look at that.
I know I have my missile.
See?
I pressed Q.
Alright, where's the boss?
Oh, is that him?
Is that him over there?
Boom!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, he dodged?
Oh, shit!
Oh, no.
That's fucking right.
Oh, my god.
He has a fucking knife!
Wait, he has a knife!
guys.
He can dodge?
Oh, this is bad.
This guy is serious.
This guy is actually serious.
Oh, I didn't mean to charge.
But we'll do it.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, I missed
He keeps dodging!
That's illegal!
Jesus Christ.
Holy shit.
That's fucking right!
Not for the babies.
Not even close.
Damn right I am.
Damn right.
right i'm so good at this look at that not even close
easiest fight of my life we uh 47 000 all right that's fine
that's fine it was worth it all right we're gonna have to
call it here guys oh i wish i could play longer that was
really fun oh i wish i could play longer guys oh my god but
thank you everybody for coming to the part one of armored
cool sorry armor core armor cool armored core i and i
literally am enjoying this game i do wish i know i want to
play longer too but today has been a really busy day today's
a busy busy busy day but thank you everybody for watching
and for the support um like if i had you man did have to
come in so soon um i would have been fine but i feel awkward
streaming while the handyman's here like i i don't really
want to dock my stuff to my handyman so i'm gonna call it
here hey guys don't worry we're gonna have two parts we're
gonna play two parts of armor core next week don't worry two
playthroughs next week hey guys as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing enemy you stay up for me head to bed guys you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody and see you
guys tonight We're at Zapongo.
We're at Zapongo.
See you guys tonight with Matara and I.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.